while there's never any shortage of
shows to binge on Netflix the streaming
service also boasts a massive
ever-changing selection of movies but
it's all too easy to take a chance on a
new film only to realize how bad it is
halfway through the movie so with that
in mind we rounded up a handful of
hidden gems on Netflix to make sure your
movie night is suck free movies like the
voices released in 2014
the voices tells the tale of a guy named
Jerry played by Ryan Reynolds who lives
a simple but lonely life as a factory
worker his only real friends are his cat
his dog and his psychopathic urges it's
a seriously dark twisted comedy anchored
by Reynolds performance as a trouble but
cheerful guy who's so out of touch with
reality that he even can't believe some
of the stuff he's doing
obviously Ryan Reynolds isn't known for
his horror movies if you've seen the
2005 Amityville Horror remake and find
it hard to believe that Reynolds could
play both funny and a legitimate creep
you should give the voices a watch do
have the greatest hair Tom
in the back it's awesome snow on the
bluff even though it's labeled as a
documentary snow on the bluff is
actually a found-footage reality film
that follows Curtis snow a real-life
armed robber after snow steals a camera
from some naive college students he
hands it to a buddy and tells him to
start filming even though it's not truly
a documentary snow on the bluff gives
the audience a chilling look at the
gritty reality of life on the street
from snows perspective while the footage
is mostly dramatized Curtis snow himself
is very real and the situations he faces
are a daily reality for many the
invitation it's hard to talk about the
invitation without spoiling the best
parts so we'll leave it at this if there
is ever a dinner party that went
downhill it's this one director Karan
Kusama
loads the movie with tension right from
the start and builds the drama in a way
that leaves you guessing right along
with the characters with great low-key
performances from Akhil Houseman and
Logan Marshall Green the invitation is a
swan dive into paranoia it's also a
welcome change of pace for Kusama whose
previous films Jennifer's Body and Aeon
Flux weren't exactly gems themselves
hidden or otherwise spectral sci-fi
thriller with style are hard to come by
if that's your kind of thing chances are
you've seen all the good ones and way
too many bad ones which makes spectral
even more of a treat
following a team of US Special Forces
who stumble across a mysterious new
enemy while on assignment in Moldova
spectral Jack's the action into the
stratosphere with lightning quick combat
scenes and several nail-biting moments
of true terror spectral isn't perfect
but it delivers what it promises a bunch
of dudes fighting for their lives
against an otherworldly threat
stick it on crank up the volume and
enjoy the ride
The Midnight Meat Train based on a short
story by horror legend Clive Barker The
Midnight Meat Train is straightforward
and extremely violent it follows a
struggling photographer played by
Bradley Cooper who uncovers some weird
goings-on in a New York subway station
late at night convinced there's a killer
on the loose even though nobody else
believes him he decides to dig deeper on
his own and finds himself drawn into an
underground world darker than he could
have imagined unfortunately some changes
at Lionsgate during the movie's release
all but guaranteed that nobody would see
the film according to Barker the studio
opted to give The Midnight Meat Train a
very limited release and second-rate
theaters in favor of promoting their
other titles like The Strangers released
the same year the result a fifth
million-dollar picture brought back only
eighty-three thousand dollars then
quietly drifted away into obscurity
queue it up on Netflix and give it the
attention it deserves because this is
honestly one of the best thrillers on
the surface right now thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]
[Applause]
you